[Musik]
meinen heutigen oft kennen sie
garantiert mit über 14 millionen
verkauften alben ist herbert grönemeyer
ja einer der erfolgreichsten musiker im
deutschsprachigen raum
seine ersten erfolge feierte er mit 28
mid bochum mit liedern wie männer
holt mich oder menschen sich in
millionen von herzen
doch grüne war ja kann weitaus mehr aus
pop und rock
seine karriere begann im schauspielhaus
bochum wo er unter peter zadek
bühnenmusik schrieb und in theaterrollen
schlitzte international berühmt wurde er
als schauspieler im film das boot die
auto- und leinwand ist er bis heute treu
geblieben als komponist von bühnen musik
und soundtracks mit ihm könnte ich nun
hier in berlin locker eine stunde vor
plaudern über paparazzi fußball uns die
deutsche seele doch viel lieber will ich
mit ihm auf tauchgang gehen mit der
frage die seine kunst seit drei
jahrzehnten durchzieht der frage nämlich
was uns menschen eigentlich ausmacht und
wie wir hier zurecht kommen ist der
vorhang fällt herzlich willkommen
herbert grönemeyer wie geht es denn den
menschen so hinein und zwanzigsten
jahrhundert der mensch glaube ich muss
sich völlig neu erfinden ich glaube der
mensch steht von der ich glaube ich
bezeichne das 21 jahrhundert als das
jahrhundert der mitmenschlichkeit
ich glaube das wird sich dahin
entwickeln überhaupt nicht ganz dreist
klingt jetzt ein bisschen versponnen
aber ich glaube dass wir merken dass wir
alle zusammen rücken das macht uns angst
da sind wir nicht gewohnt
die welt ist völlig geöffnet aber nicht
nur greifen und die grenzen von der
jeder weiß alles jeder mensch weil sie
alles bescheid was überall passiert und
ich glaube dass wir nicht gewohnt sind
ja angst davor dass wir angst haben aber
gleichzeitig merken was passiert was
neues und ich glaube in der damit steckt
für mich eine schönheit weil wir glaube
ich wieder lernen nach gleich mal das
sonst ist die abwahl nicht natürlich die
wir durch die weltkriege natürlich auch
geprägt aber dann auch durch und großes
ego manisches verständnis jeder für sich
also so wie sich gesellschaft
und dieser umbruch jetzt dass man merkt
damit ist man an die wand gefahren damit
kommt man nicht weiter im soll so ist
beendet glaube ich dass diese diese
obwohl dass wir jetzt im moment
natürlich absurd klingt wenn man denkt
das ist genau das gegenteil was sie
gerade entwickelt ich glaube dass wir
zusammenrücken und dass wir ganz stark
davon leben werden dass wir uns wieder
für den anderen interessieren dass wir
lernen zuzuhören und dass wir für einen
anderen menschen uns interessieren es
ist ja auch so eine zeit um einen
eindruck posiert so unglaublich viel der
mensch steht ein stück weit auch einfach
unter strom
ja weil er ist nervös nervös merkt dass
die dass sie mit denen regeln oder mit
den grundsätzen mit den er jetzt also
ich bin jetzt 60 jahre alt ich werd
jetzt 60 jahre alt ich habe in meinem
leben im gründung keine größere
herausforderung erlebt ich werde ich
habe viele dinge erlebt die auf der welt
in krisen waren aber in meiner eigenen
also meiner eigenen umgebung hier in
deutschland habe ich im grunde genommen
was was meine umgebung angeht nichts da
musste ich mich nicht stellen
und das muss ich jetzt plötzlich muss
was ihn weltkrieg oder den weg oder wie
einfach eine neue herausforderung wie
jetzt im grunde ja auch einen notstand
entstanden ist will ich kriege die die
überall auf der welt passieren und armut
und und arm und reich verhelfen und ich
glaube das macht uns natürlich nervös
weil wir sind natürlich ein monster
unter komfortzone einfach so uns
gemütlich gemacht
sie sprechen die flüchtlingskrise jetzt
das ist eins von den themen die das auch
wieder die das auch wieder
bestätigen dass die welt einfach sich
aufeinander zu gerät und wir haben uns
einfach bequem und gemütlich gemacht und
gedacht alles andere das nicht sagen wir
wir kommen irgendwie so durch bis zum
schluss und jetzt sagt uns aber hier die
die welt und die gesellschaft auf das so
nicht bewusst ich jetzt und das meiner
meinung
ich sehe das sogar so weit ist darin nur
ein geschenk steckt dass er einfach noch
einmal die gelegenheit haben also das
villinger haben um zu denken neu zu
denken und das gehirn neue umzuschalten
und einfach wir sind euch nicht zur welt
hinaus gegangen jetzt kommt die funktion
sodass das werde ich ganz schön ihre
enten ihr neuestes album heißt ja
dauernd jetzt damit machen sie im moment
auch eine große tour durch den
deutschsprachigen raum werden im zehnten
juni in st gallen auch auftreten mit
dauernd jetzt dauernd jetzt ist das auch
so ein bisschen die temperatur des
menschen im moment oder nur ihre
temperatur grönemeyer versucht aber dazu
sagen dass ist das ist dieser diese
platte hat eine mischung von von
persönlich dass das leben mehr an sich
sich wieder sehr zugewandt hat auf meine
eigenen ich habe vor meine mein bruder
meine meine frau da wo wir vor dem vor
17 jahren gestorben und in der gleichen
woche alle innerhalb von vier tagen
und jetzt habe ich aber das gefühl das
leben hat sich mir wieder unter die
künftige schoben gleichzeitig behandelt
die platte aber eben auch plötzlich ganz
stark auseinander mit der mit der
thematik dass das mit dem in deutschland
selber der zerrissenheit die sich jetzt
auftut auch nach 25 jahren nach der
wiedervereinigung und gleichzeitig eben
auch was die was die flüchtlingsbewegung
angehen aber dennoch glaube ich dass sie
in diesem jetzt zu leben was sehr schön
ist und das beschreibt ist an sich eine
optimistische platte die sich aber nicht
versucht vor dem problem die um mich
herum bringt
zu verschließen ich komme auf die
schicksalsschläge danach ja gleich noch
zurück bei mir noch kurz bei die sind
jetzt ich muss sagen ich finde diesen
titel ganz toll dauernd jetzt und zwar
deswegen weil ich denke dass ich
eigentlich ein bisschen ein widerspruch
in sich jetzt kann ja nicht dauern und
gleichzeitig habe das so was wunderbar
buddhistische sich diese vorstellung
dass man das jetzt so sehr aus kostet
das eigentlich dauernd jetzt ist dass
man den moment festhalten kann nicht so
sehr dauernd die vergangenheit
analysiert nicht zu sehr dauernd plant
ich finde es aber auch eine sehr
anspruchsvolle sagen wir mal neben sie
die ja das ist es sagt was sie sagen es
ist die dass man es lernt den dem moment
zu strecken
dann heißt wenn wir den moment dauert
nur sekunden vier sekunden einen moment
kann aber auch ein grundgefühl sein was
man wenn man sich daran festmachen
einfach über lange zeit strecken kann
das heißt ja nicht dass man dass man
lernt nicht ständig auf was zu zu leben
sondern dem moment würden es gibt da
dieses in den meditationen wenn man das
achtsamkeit aber dass man einfach lernt
zu begreifen wie fühlt sich das jetzt im
moment an was ist das und ich war immer
jemand auch zum leidwesen meiner eltern
denn ich habe nie geplant ich habe auch
nie ich wollte auch nie sänger werden
das hat sich so ergeben sich immer
gesungen habe ich wollte an sich habe
jura studiert und wollte an sich die
fußballer oder gebrauchtwarenhändler
wird aber gesungen habe ich immer und
ich glaube dass man das leben auch nicht
planen kann ich glaub ich glaube nicht
sondern hört man kann dem moment greifen
so wenn wir jetzt hier zusammensitzen
das ist für mich dass du jetzt findet
mein leben statt das ist mein leben was
jetzt heute noch passiert weiß ich nicht
das ist das was jetzt
und darin steckt eine schönheit und das
wenn man das schafft so weit wie möglich
zu strecken dann ist das dieses dieses
gefühl dann glaube ich hatte meine
anderen halt und auch eine andere
sicherheit meditieren sie selber ich
hab' ich werde tiere auch ja ich nicht
jetzt täglich aber ich habe die
transzendentale meditation beibringen
lassen
es gibt dort sehr gute meditation im
hatte ich jetzt keine werbung dafür
machen das gibt aber auch als als app
die erstmal head space das kann man wie
ich sehr empfehlen und ich habe die
gleiche m
naja mal interessanterweise ich habe
eine psychologin
in england haben untersuchungen gemacht
und gesagt wenn man täglich also rein
wissenschaftlich dass der schule
medizinerin
wenn man täglich 20 minuten einfach
innehält und meditiert dann innerhalb
von vier monaten halbiert sich das
angstzentrum ernähren
das kann man nach weiteren kernspin und
das finde ich ganz ich glaube einfach
ich glaube dass wir auf der anderen
seite unserem gehirn zu wenig auszeit
gönnen sich interessiert weil meine
beiden eltern davon betroffen denn von
von auch von demenzen und ich habe mich
immer interessiert ob das nicht damit zu
tun hat dass wir immer glauben wir
müssen latent aktiv seien geistig und
wären gehirn im grunde um die ruhepause
nicht glaube einfach dass ich habe ich
gesagt probiere ich das machen es ist
deswegen auch interessant weil ich vor
gar nicht allzu langer zeit schon körper
ziehen interviewt habe das ist sozusagen
der gründer dieser achtsamkeit bewegung
dieser meint von es bewegung
und die hat ja moment tatsächlicher
unglaublichen zulauf und ein grund
könnte ja eben sein dass wir dauernd
jetzt auch überfordern trinken also
dieser eindruck dass zb durchs internet
eben überhaupt keine zeiten keine
abstände mehr vorhanden sind sondern
vergangenheit und zukunft fließen
ineinander wir können alle informationen
dauern haben wir können auch dauernd
alles wieder nachschlagen das internet
vergisst ja nichts wir können auch
dauern die schon in die zukunft planen
es war fließt alles und es gibt einen
medientheoretiker der heißt dass roßkopf
er hat den begriff geprägt des gegenwart
schocks und dieser begriff der hat mich
irgendwie fasziniert weil ich gedacht
hatte dass hab etwas dieser dieses
dieses gefühl davon dass die gegenwart
dieses jetzt also überrollt wie in der
maschinerie
kennen sie dieses gefühl auch und ja das
kann ich ja das ist ja auch genau der
grund weil nicht mehr mit dieser wucht
dagegen warten weil ich so massive in
dem schreiben
auch kulturell von allen seiten und und
das ist dass das projekt oder art zu
sprechen weil wird und kaum noch trauen
was zu sagen wenn ich jetzt den falschen
satz hier sagen würde dann wird das
hatte gleich morgen die wie wild den
keine ahnung als kontrolliert und
gleichzeitig
wenn man aber weiß so ist es dann muss
man natürlich einen weg suchen wie gehe
ich damit um
und es gibt zwei möglichkeiten entweder
ich lasse mich treiben in meiner unruhe
oder lerne okay ich werde bleibt ruhig
oder ich bin jetzt drin in dieser im
gegensatz schock also wie gehe ich damit
um und wenn was wenn etwas hysterisch
wird oder nervös dann ist im grunde um
die normale die normale fähigkeit des
menschen dass er noch mal zur ruhe
kommen sollte also genau geguckt was ist
ja nicht wirklich los und das versuche
ich glaube in diesem die der schock die
dagegen weiter so druckvoll dass man
ganz ruhig werden muss um das zu
sortieren und das zu finden was ein was
man will und gleichzeitig auch lernt das
wegzulassen wahrscheinlich interessiert
und was wir nicht brauchen
das ist auch so leicht schreibt zb ich
antworte auch nicht auf mails oder sms
direkt mache das manchmal wie früher
beim brief schreibe ich verantworte dann
wochen später oder sie haben trotzdem
ich glaube dass dieses dieses dieses
immer vorhanden sein müssen diese
patente haben wenn man jemand schreibt
und er schreibt mich zurück da liegt ja
ein schon nicht mehr weil er nicht
reagieren wenn er nur eine stunde später
schreibe liebte einfach nur 87,5 prozent
ich glaube dieses und in diesem ganzen
und der ganzen unruhe glaube ich ist die
schönheit zu gucken wie komme ich dazu
ruhe die komik so hohe und das und dann
kommen auch diese kulturellen
begegnungen dass wenn man zb eben auch
nach afrika fährt zb dann merkt man die
leute haben trotzdem dass es den sehr
schlecht geht eine unheimliche ruhe sind
sie oft ich war mehrmals in afrika oder
dieses wasser überrascht es diese wenn
man jetzt eine tochter aber gerade in
uganda habe ich das genauso erklärt
vorweg weil die haben wirklich angst
gehabt die schweiz nach uganda und dann
hört wirst dich wundern wenn du
hinkommst wirklich eine unglaubliche
ruhe wird ja eine unheimliche ruhe
begeben
damit rechnen wir nicht wir sagen afrika
oh gott oh gott da ist ganz furchtbar
aber speziell zentralafrika und ich
waren obernheimer im kongo ich war in
tansania in uganda
da begegnet einem eine unheimliche ruhe
die menschen haben
denn gezählt der cherry fällen ist aber
trotzdem beginnt einfach eine
unglaubliche das nicht gewohnt sind wir
europäer oder silvester gar nicht mehr
gewohnt und denken und dieses zu finden
diese diese fähigkeit auch hier zu
finden so langsam oder gerade jetzt auch
in zeiten wo die menschen ängste haben
hysterisch werden nach rechts rücken
aufschreien wenn einer gerade wieder der
kranke nicht richtig sitzt gerade da
muss man langsam ganz langsam ganz ruhig
und insofern denke ich hat hat diese
achtsamkeit oder diese meditation hat
was er so eine esoterische überbaut wird
ganz pragmatisch sieht diese richtung ja
auch gar nicht ich denke mir manchmal
vielleicht ist die aufgabe ja text
tatsächlich im 21 jahrhundert wach zu
bleiben ohne zu ermüden weil ich oft
irgendwie denke da hat ja der therapie
und schulraum denn sie manchmal auch in
interviews selber erwähnen der
koreanischstämmige philosoph der ja auch
in berlin lebt der grundschule horn hat
diesen begriff der müdigkeit
gesellschaft geprägt um diese
vorstellung dass wir alles unendlich
müde auch werden weil das tempo so hoch
leben und kann man einfach nicht mehr
und dann denke ich mir immer das ist
wahrscheinlich auch die kunst auch wach
zu bleiben ohne müde zu werden
das kann man aber nur dann wenn man sich
auch auszeiten nimmt wenn ich hier keine
aussagen nehmen dann legt sich
irgendwann die müdigkeit latent über
mich war dann merke ich laufe ja aber
ich mir die auszeiten nehmen wieder
aufzutanken
dann kann ich auch wieder wesentlich
wacher wieder denkt sich der gegenwart
stellen und das denke ich daran kein
stück auch sonst will lässt man sonst
ist dieses dieser dieser dieses
umtreiben macht dann macht eigentlich
wenn ich ihre musik hören und das tue
ich schon sehr lange dann kriege ich
immer auch den eindruck wenn über den
menschen sprechen
sie sehen den menschen in erster linie
eigentlich auch auf ein beziehungs wesen
sie hatten ja am anfang auch gesagt wir
rücken näher zusammen aber eigentlich
zieht sich das schon lange glaube ich
durch ihre musik auch zum beispiel in
ihrem lied fangen nicht an ich würde
gerne mit ihnen einen höheren in dieses
stück das sich auch auf der neuen platte
befindet gut
[Musik]
zu sehen komisch ich war ja man sieht
das alter mann ist an sieht sie so dass
ich gucke mir das nie an ich komme
meinem eine weile konzert mitschnitte
sanieren nicht auch keine
fernsehauftritte ich habe jetzt nur
geguckt
das war komisch sehr komisch ich mache
das stückgut was ich schön finde da man
oder auch interessante darüber möchte
ich mit ihnen reden ist dass die
quintessenz dieses liedes für mich so
ein bisschen ist wir komplettieren uns
gegenseitig und eigentlich dadurch dass
wir lieben und geliebt werden werden wir
ganz kommt irgendwie glaube ich auch in
vielen liedern von ihnen vor
und da frage ich mich dann stimmt das
wirklich oder was würden sie sagen dass
ich dann mit einer person die sehr
einsam ist die alleine lebt vielleicht
auch gewollt alleine lebt kann die sich
nie ganz erkennen oder was fehlt dir das
klar ja dass ich glaube dass wir geld
generell und selber nur zu wenn man das
wort prozent sagen wir einfach keine 48
prozent selber wahrnehmen und kennen das
glaube ich das klingt und mehr gelingt
uns nicht im leben und die restlichen 50
wenn man damit jemand zusammenkommt oder
auch mit freunden ich glaube nicht mehr
dass das jetzt partner sein müssen aber
in der liebe soll ich glaube dass die
reflektion mit freunden werden wir
gespiegelt und die in dieser spiegelung
diese freude sehen dann natürlich von
außen gesehen andere dinge und die
tragen einem zu noch im sommer von den
restlichen 50 noch mal 24 oder 25 und
das war es dann auch glaube bis zum ende
des lebens mehr schafft man nicht aber
man selber ist glaube ich ein wenn man
alleine ist nicht in der lage oder die
frage ist will man das überhaupt so muß
es ja nicht auch nicht unbedingt sagen
aber ich glaube hier selber sondern
unserer selbstwahrnehmung auch von der
fähigkeit um das gehirn sind nun in der
lage und 50 prozent zur hälfte von der
ak 55 sein wahrzunehmen deswegen
brauchen wir die gemeinschaft und die
freuen und natürlich auch natürlich auch
die natürlich die liebe oder jemand mit
dem man zusammen ist nun plötzlich so
geschehen auch die teile zum
mitzukriegen der mann der gegen selber
gar nicht gewesen die man gar nicht
versteht wie man auch gar nicht die
außenwirkung und das ist die schönheit
und das ist nicht glauben dass irgendwie
ganz ganz schön gesagt dieses
gemeinschaft der mensch ist ein
gemeinschafts wesen glaube ich was
gesagt und das glaube ich dass die das
ist in meinen augen das was ein bissle
beträgt
mein vater hat das immer gepredigt hat
immer gedacht das einzige was dem leben
haben wer ist alles wichtig sind am
leben ist in freundschaften und da das
sehr gepflegt und er hat dann später
dann als er älter wurde eine sehr
schnelle live body demand die sehr sehr
sehr schnell sehr kompliziert und das
hat er kommen sehen und ihm war und wenn
er als er dann eine sehr viele freunde
aus dem studium und 50 jahren und auch
aus dem kriege und wenn wir zu ihm kam
wurde immer unruhig er hat nicht mehr
gesprochen und da wird es immer und wenn
die kammer war ganz ruhig
die großen betty war zum teil 90 waren
über morgens ist komplettieren selbst
noch in der demenzen stück weit die
brachten ihn zur ruhe die brachte und
das war da immer gesagt hat alles was du
ganz erfolg haben da kann es geld haben
kann also wenn du die freundschaft nicht
hast dann wirst du wird er gerade in der
phase wurde dann anfängt natürlich auch
viel über deine seele nachzulegen über
die endlichkeit und generell im leben
und das hat er zelebriert und der reine
eine lerne er in brust von lebensfreude
und obwohl der januar der sehen waren
er hat seinen eigenen vater verloren mit
mit vier jahren weil der mann großvater
bergwerksdirektor und wer da waren gas
einbruch in der wobei der musste mit
seiner mutter daneben stand oben am loch
und der vater stück runter war sofort
tot vor den augen von meinem vater also
der staat quasi vorhin dann hat er seine
hand verloren in stalingrad das glaube
ich natürlich zum glück rausgekommen und
klingt jetzt alles so dramatisch ist es
auch sicherlich nicht lustig oder aber
er hatte das leben oder das leben eines
vor lebensfreude und und und hat auch er
wird immer toller umso älter werden wird
wird immer teurer
er wird immer stärker wie ein baum und
da wird immer toller und und kräftiger
und gerade von ein schläger oder noch
wird er immer schön aber prächtiger und
ihrem umfeld den umsatz sondern war es
das auch oder war das auch der hatte
auch nie weil so auch in dem sie in
anführungsstrichen auch keine angst vorm
sterben sicherlich vom vom leiden aber
nicht vom sterben und hat das leben in
aller wucht genossen oder aber und aber
immer in dieser in dieser konstellation
auch immer mit seinen freund und zwar
jetzt gerade noch bei deinem nachbarn
übertragen weil wenn ich meine mutter
besuchte er ist jetzt 95 gemeinderat gar
nicht ganz präzise messerscharf
rasierklinge also dass die rating auch
bar die nachbarin nicht direkt
dem unternehmen unter den nachbarn
geträumt jetzt erzählte genau das auch
die schön das war diese diese
gemeinschaft mit meinem fahrrad oder mit
dem freuen wenn ihr am tisch saßen und
geredet haben und der präzise auch an
wer also auch damit debattiert wie auch
immer ich glaube dass wir mensch ist ein
gemeinwesen mannschaft gewesen und ich
glaube darin steckt die große schönheit
das heißt der mensch der erkennt sich
mehr wenn er mit freunden zusammen nicht
spiegelnden stückweise komplettieren
ihnen wie sie wie sie sagen
gleichzeitig kommen sie auch darauf
hingewiesen am anfang mit den
schicksalsschlägen zu lieben sich
einzulassen ist immer auch ein risiko
weil wenn man liebt dann bindet man sich
man macht sich auch verletzlich weil man
kaum wieder brutal verlieren und das
wissen sie selber ganz genau 1998 war
das eben ihre frau anna henkel gestorben
ist an krebs viel zu früh am tag habe
ich von 42 jahren 45 und ihr bruder in
der gleichen woche
ich habe noch nie einen menschen
verloren der mehr so nah gestanden ist
wie verändert das leben ja dass es also
erstmal das natürlich die ultimative
katastrophe
gleichzeitig war es so so so so
überdimensional das malheur der
engländer sagen wir warten am mann war
man fühlte sich nicht mehr und umgekehrt
kriegt man sich eine größere demuth vom
leben und erkennt aber dann auch wieder
natürlich auch diese unfassbare
schönheit des lebens weil man eben mit
miterleben musste
[Musik]
was passiert was menschen dazu stößt was
mit menschen passiert welches leid die
erfahrung und das ist relativiert
natürlich wieder vieles
ich glaube es das leben wird wird in
jeder beziehung es gibt eine farbe die
man vorher nicht hatte die läuft mit die
bleibt auch da die bleibt immer
vorhanden ist ein farbton den hatte mal
in seiner rede auch durch so ein
farbschema strahlt auch er ist ein ganz
farbiges wesen und da plötzlich addiert
sich eine farbe die war vorher nicht da
das ist sieht man das nennen
helles grau oder was für eine farbe kann
auch ein dunkles grünen seien aber seine
farbe die seine farbe die nicht darben
und die fängt man an und die bleibt
immer bei 1
zum glück hatte da ist das leben so
geschaffen dass die anderen farben oder
irgendwann auch wieder in farbe gewinnen
und dann ist die daten bleibt diese
farbe da aber überdeckt nicht alles
andere aber es ist eine neue ist einen
neuen ersten mann hat und die bleibt
vorhanden aber die läuft immer mit einem
mit und gleichzeitig ist es aber glaube
ich auch so dass es auch eine essenz des
lebens weil es eindeutig auch die
endlichkeit natürlich ganz klar vor
augen hält
es gab ja viele philosophen angefangen
mit platon später senica die betont
haben
eigentlich ist philosophieren nichts
anderes als sterben zu lernen und ich
frage mich immer lernt man denn auch
etwas wie das eigene sterben wenn man
andere sterben sieht ist das ein
philosophischer moment auch also erstmal
das natürlich ein sehr existenzieller
und strenger moment oder der ein guter
freund von mir gerade gestorben ist was
also mich sehr beliebt ist
ja der guter freund von mir haben in den
nüchtern satz der todes sehr banal dass
ich mich sehr sehr spezielle sehens
weise ich glaube dass ich glaube schon
dass das die vorbereitung das leben ist
eben eine latente auseinandersetzung
täglich minütlich alle viertelstunde
keine ahnung
mit der existenz das ist schon so aber
will dass das sterben lernen finde ich
dann auch so ein bisschen dafür ist der
vorgang hatte des sterbens auch nicht
den kann man nicht lernen nicht nur
gelernt wie man mit dem leben
niemand muss das ist ich glaube wie man
mit sich selber klar wie man wie man wie
man mit dem mit dem sterben vielleicht
einer gewissen form freundschaft
schließen kann
das klingt jetzt ein bisschen platt oder
vielleicht ein bisschen aber ich glaube
das ist die frage wie schafft man sie im
leben sich darauf einzustellen
mit denen mit dem mit dem mit dem mit
dem tod in kontakt zu treten
warum gerade ich glaube und das ist
glaube ich machbar wenn nicht dieses
leid dazu kommt weil man natürlich das
leid sie sich plötzlich in den weg
stellt seinen anfangs regung dann wird
es komplexe glaube dieses leiden vorm
sterben ist das aller schwierigkeit
glaube ansonsten aber auseinander so
dass man endlich ist glaube ich das geht
das kriegt man glaube ich in dieser form
hin dass man vorher noch extrem sliden
mussten das ist gemein da wird dann
willig gemeinde diese und dann ist das
sterben auch nicht ist ja nun auch nicht
gerade ein vorgang der mal eben so dazu
gehört auch sehr viel kraft zu sterben
habe der vorherige sterben es ist nicht
wie man sich vorstellt leider nicht so
gestaltet vom lieben gott dass man mal
eben im stuhl sitzt also gab es gibt es
auch die daneben so leicht zur seite
kippen uns war es dann viele müssen
dummerweise im sterben auch noch ein
hagen weg gehen
und der ist nicht da glaube ich das ist
es nicht
es können nicht nicht so heute die haben
ja eigentlich diese schicksalsschläge
ein stück weit auch verarbeitet wenn das
wahr arbeiten kommen und wenn man das
verarbeiten will in der platte mensch
das ist das meistverkaufte album
überhaupt im deutschsprachigen raum und
auf dieser platte gibt es auch das
titelgebende stück mensch und darstellen
die den menschen voraus anwesen der ganz
viele dinge tut er vergisst zum beispiel
verzeichnet sich auch der macht der
weint aber der ring doch mit sich ich
habe den eindruck das ist ein wesen das
sich in frage gestellt dass es auch
immer mal wieder an die grenzen kommt
was sehr glücklich sein kann aber auch
sehr traurig glauben sie dass das allen
menschen so geht oder ist vielleicht
gerade der einbruch des schicksals
sozusagen einen moment wenn das
schicksal an die tür klopft
indem es den menschen daneben gelingt
sich in frage zu stellen
also ich glaube grundsätzlich dass sich
jeder mensch latent in falsche sein und
unsicher sei eben auch in der spiegelung
mit freunden in der gesellschaft mit mit
seiner mit einer mit seinem leben an
sich wie wie läuft das läuft das richtig
bin ich glücklich bin ich unglücklich
habe ich glück im leben hat der andere
mehr glück als ich war meine mutter
liebt zu mir oder war die liebe zu einer
schwester oder was auch immer ich glaube
die auseinandersetzung haben wir immer
ich glaube wenn man die
schicksalsschläge bringen ein vielleicht
decken ein insofern auch gesagt so jetzt
musst du dich vielleicht mal etwas
entspannter aber direkt damit dem leben
auseinandersetzen und es gibt eine
wunderbare auswahl von einer dame diese
gestorben sondern im sterben lagen haben
sie gefragt haben wie man das was würden
sie denn heute anders machen und er hat
die den schönen satz gehört ich hatte
unheimlich viel angst das habe ich im
nachhinein da macht das alles gar keinen
sinn diese ängste mit denen wir uns auch
um geben ich glaube das ist die ich
glaube in einem die bin dann das
schicksal trifft in der form wie sich
nun das ausgedacht hat für mich dann
wird man angst feuer das schon glauben
und merkt dass die ängste die man mit
mit sich selber hatte ist er zum teil
auch schon so wenn man kinder bekommt
aber wenn man sich so an dadurch geht
dann merkt man mit angstfreier deutlich
angst vorher weil man merkt dass man mit
ängsten
das heißt nicht angstfrei bin aber ich
bin deutlich unbelastet werden ängste
als ich vorher war und weil man ängste
haben viel mit selbstgeschriebenen
nabelschau zu tun und egoismus und und
das glaube ich könnte mal einfach durch
den dieses diesen tiefschlag diesem
existenziellen schreiben wird man
sicherlich nimmt man dinge etwas
gelassener bzw
merkt dass diese edlen ängste die man
zum teil auch hat dass die natürlich
total bescheuert sind ihr stück angst
das ist ja schon
dafür gibt es auch kommen das gehört
tatsächlich zu einem meiner
lieblingsstücke aber da sprechen wir
jetzt nicht nicht länger drüber aber das
hat ja unglaublich viele facetten aus
angst alle verdienen kann
aber ich wollte zurückkommen zur familie
und zwar zu ihrer aussage sind wir ja
mal gesagt eine ist für sie die ganze
gesellschaft auch so was wie eine
familie
das ist eigentlich eine riesen familie
überfordert uns das nicht die diese
vorstellung dass die menschheit an sich
auch so was wie eine familie ist
letztendlich ist ja doch eigentlich ich
weiß nicht unser freundeskreis ist uns
näher und man sich dieser eindruck dass
wir das mitleid jetzt global ausdehnen
sollen die sich am anfang auch ein
stückweit gesagt haben
auch ein bisschen überfordert für uns ja
aber das ist exakt der punkt wenn man
wenn man mitleid hat man nicht mit der
familie um die familie kümmern wollen
sich wittler hat man oft mit menschen
den schlecht geht oder schwächer sind
aber wie in mitleid steckt auch zum teil
immer ein bisschen was überhebliches und
ich glaube wenn man die welt als eine
familie begreifen würde dann würde man
die ganz simplen strukturen begraben
dann wenn es jemandem schlecht geht in
der familie
dann hilft der dem es bessergeht das ist
so dass ich das also in der gesellschaft
so oder den bewerbern zwar für der welt
wenn man nur deutschland oder in europa
um
und ich glaube dann geht man anderen
ansatz weil dann sieht man das nicht als
als mitglied einer familie mein bruder
den schräg kernig aus mitleid sondern
weil das ist mein bruder und dem denn
der hat nicht das glück hatte wie ich
dass ich jetzt total also zum beispiel
ich als als ich habe jetzt das glück ich
hab was gefunden mit dem ich zum teil
waren da nicht gleich geld verdienen das
gibt es in jeder familie einer da etwas
gefunden der väterlich geld mit daran
gearbeitet viel härter dem geht es viel
schlechter oder hat wir über pech gehabt
oder so dann ist der familie ist völlig
selbstverständlich also sollte
selbstverständlich sein dass man dann
denjenigen hilft und wenn man die
gesellschaft oder die welt so sehen
würde dann würde man erst mal weg kommen
von dem mitleid sondern wird einfach
begreifen das ist ein teil von mir
das ist ein teil von mir also überlegen
wie kann ich dessen situation verbessern
und wie nur dann kann ich mich selber
auch wieder durchatmen ich glaube ist da
steckt aber ich glaube dass er
wenn es der familie ein um der familie
schlecht geht dann ist weiß man das und
das tut einem wird das dass das bedrückt
und ich glaube und das macht sie selber
auch betroffen das macht dann betroffen
und dann hat man kann dann leidet man
mit ich bin mittag immer schwierig
sondern es ist wirklich diesen mann
kümmert sich umeinander das und dann
steckt eine schönheiten das ist schön
und umgekehrt ja auch weil ich weiß dass
mein bruder würde auch wenn es mir
schlecht geht
ich habe mich gehören meine schwester
und wenn man das und wenn man so die
gesellschaft sieht university glaubt
dann ist es steckt daran eine größere
also empathische beziehung als jedes
mitleid weil mitleid finde ich es immer
so dass ich mir unter googles person
sie engagieren sich ja auch schon sehr
lange sie haben sich zb am g-8-gipfel
2007 engagiert sie sehen hier ein bild
von ihnen zusammen mit bob geldof und
bono da haben sie für schulen bhs
plädiert für mehr entwicklungshilfe
heute finanzieren zum teil flüchtlings
projekte sie treten auch am
benefizkonzert auf tun sie das alles aus
mensch herbert grönemeyer oder
verpflichtet sie auch ihre berühmtheit
als erster gehen heute das als mensch
ich kann aufgrund meiner berühmtheit
oder auch meine wenn er sagen wir auch
finanziellen möglichkeiten natürlich
vielleicht zum teil mehr machen da ich
habe keine öffentlichkeit herstellen da
muss mehr machen es falsch ich mache
nicht mehr je weniger ich kann mit
meiner popularität natürlich
öffentlichkeit herstellen das können
viele aber die viel harte arbeit auch in
den in den in den hilfen in den in den
silos und in den organisationen die wir
aber nicht dieses diese für mich sind
die medien teil meines mannes werkzeugs
aber gleichzeitig denke ich dass man
dass man
dass man auch gerade in zeiten wie
diesen die so wackelig werden dass man
auch eine haltung haben muss oder muss
auch gegenüber sich selber eine haltung
aber auch gegenüber seinen ängsten
erhalten haben und insofern finde es
eher eine menschliche regung als sich
nur denken weil ich jetzt populär bin
oder erfolgreich muss ich jetzt was tun
sondern ich glaube aber als mensch
gehört das dazu
und ich habe jetzt einfach die
möglichkeiten aber wieder dass das ich
wollte mich auch früher schon engagieren
und da war ich nicht populär genau über
die grünen zum beispiel deutschland
dauert gab es da noch eine bewegung die
grüne raupe als sie anfing ihren
solisten die hitlisten und es dann nicht
mehr ganz so nicht wird gern mitsingen
sondern er denkt im büro nicht das habe
ich der tierischen ich habe dann auch
nie was die grünen getan hat mich
tierisch geärgert mal sehen ob ich
glaube es ist eine frage des menschen
glaube weil ich komme aus dem ruhrgebiet
ich bin groß geworden
dagegen wurden in der arbeiter gegen und
da war das einfach so man lernt man
lernte oder die kultur des ruhrgebiets
war damit verknüpft dass die menschen
morgens in einfuhren in die erde
und schon beim einfuhren im lift geguckt
haben wir holt mich hier raus am abend
wenn wir was passiert wer holt mich hier
raus also ganz aber jeden tag war es
existenziell war jeden tag wenn man 1000
meter unter die erde fährt geht es nur
noch darum wer passt auf mich auf und
wer hilft mir und das ist die mentalität
der menschen im ruhrgebiet und und so
wird man da groß dass man verantwortung
hat man eine verantwortung für jeden
einzelnen der im ruhrgebiet lebt und das
prägt ein sehr sie haben jetzt mehrere
male darauf hingewiesen dass sie einfach
auch sehr viel glück kaufen oder zufall
ist dass sie jetzt so viel tun können
was im ring geworden sind auf der skala
wenn die samen werden wie viel prozent
ihres erfolgs haben sie sich selber
zuzuschreiben war wirklich eine
situation in der ich lebe also außerhalb
von denen den schicksalsschlägen die ja
aber wenn man dieses wird was mein beruf
angeht da bin ich schon ein extrem
glücklichen situation dass ich das ich
dass ich das was ich gerne gemacht habe
machen kann gleichzeitig damit auch viel
geld verdienen die leute gerne kommen
werden wir ganz verblüfft dass die noch
kommen oder warum das ist schon das ist
schon ein großes gewissen unglaublich
geschenk das man auf der bühne stehen
kann und den menschen phosphor sinkt und
dann folgen macht man denn eine freude
das liegt natürlich auf mich zurück da
freue ich mich auch noch viel mehr aber
das ist schon ultimatives glück das ist
das kann man nicht alles was anders
beschreiben und das ist zufall natürlich
habe ich das habe ich auch noch
zusätzlich ein gewisses talent
mitbekommen habe wohl anscheinend und
das bekommen haben und da
demgegenüber die talente auch eine
gewisse verantwortung habe damit
liebevoll umzugehen aber die ich lebe
schon sehr privilegierten situation und
was das angeht da sehr glücklichen
situation
sie hatten den biss dranzubleiben wir
werden ja immer wieder wie sie als
kleiner junge mit morning has broken an
geburtstagen die verwandten genervt
haben und dann trotzdem weiter gesungen
haben ziemlich glücksspiel deswegen wenn
wir noch haben über den menschen
sprechen herr grönemeyer ja sie sind ja
nicht nur ein mensch wie ich einer bin
sondern sich ein stück weit auch eine
kunstfigur das hat das so an sich wären
berühmt ist was genau mögen sie an der
kunstfigur herbert grönemeyer und wer
ist diese kunstfigur im verhältnis zu
ihnen selber kids da wirklich große
differenzen oder wenn sie sagen
eigentlich näher ich mich doch immer
wieder auch der kunstfiguren umgekehrt
sehr kompliziert ich glaube sicherlich
stilisiert man sich
sicherlich habe ich die fähigkeit
aufgrund auch dieser meiner art jetzt
inzwischen mit worten umzugehen
natürlich mache ich mich in meinen
liedern besser als ich bin also man
stilisiert sich hoch und schraubt sich
hoch mann ist mann ist ich bin eben kein
dokumentarfilm sollten spielfilm also
insofern und da muss man sehr vorsichtig
sein man soll auch glaube ich nie also
würde ich mich streng sind gehen wir von
der kunst auf den künstler schließen
das sind zwei verschiedene paar schuhe
sondern der eine hat die bessere
fähigkeit sich toller darzustellen als
der andere trotzdem regeln hat man
gesagt von element of crime der frontman
dass man ja auch nicht bei einem beben
künstler und fragt ob das auf den
bildern nicht er ist ja ist also
natürlich zählen wir alle aber selbst
wenn man ein liebesbrief schreibt an
seine freundin oder erzählen wir alle
von unseren erfahrungen und schnee
schlagen sich nieder in der kunst die
wir machen aber dennoch tun wir alles um
natürlich in der öffentlichkeit in dem
was wir machen toll da zu stehen das ist
ja also ich werde jetzt wir machen
sicher nicht runter sondern wir
beschreiben was ja als wahnsinnig klug
und nachdenklich oder oder will ich
kenne das ja oft dass leute
er muss ja wirklich sehr dem will ich
mich gerne da muss ja sehr sehr gutes
sehen zuweisen über das leben und die
würde ich dann vielleicht auch schon ein
bisschen mit mir zusammen selbst sondern
man macht aus sicht der kunstfiguren und
die annäherung glauben ich auf der bühne
stehe und singe dann ist es glaube ich
kann sagen wir in einer halben stunde
bin ich dann schon sehr eng mit mir
zusammen aber was auf den platten ist
oder was ich singe sind sind
verklausuliert themen die mich berühren
und mitbewegen aber trotzdem sind sie
sehr sehr fein hochstilisierte das ganze
popbusiness das pop beschäftigte
eigentlich nichts anderes sogar sehr
sehr stark auch ein spiel mit der ganzen
inszenierung denken wir an kunstfiguren
oder figuren wie lady gaga oder miley
cyrus oder und david bowie der vor
kurzem gestorben ist ja die inszenierung
perfekt beherrscht hat sich immer wieder
neues gesicht geben eine neue figur
spielen
damit haben sie selber nie so sehr
gespielt sie sind doch eigentlich mehr
oder weniger zumindest fürs publikum
suggerieren sie dass sie eine
authentische person sind ja aber ich
habe diese authentizität stilisiert ich
glaube das ist das
es ist das ist david bowie hat sich
gesehen in der größeren theatralik hörte
ich immer wieder verändert immer figuren
erfunden und ich erfinde hat die
authenzität immer wieder neu so die das
sagen also aber diese diese wenn man
nicht auf der bühne stehen würde und
würde nicht eine kunstfigur sein dann
hätte man gar nicht diese ausstrahlung
man hätte könnte gar nicht die
menschenwürde gar nicht
das ist wie theater oder
jungschauspieler nicht die rolle
überziehe und hochfahren
also dieses material was ich bekomme von
den dramen dann gehe ich hin als
schauspiel ich war jetzt nicht so ein
großer schauspieler die großen
schauspieler die die haben nur diese
präsenz auf der bühne füllen nur den
raum weil sie das bis zum stehkragen
hochfahren und das mache ich auf der
bühne auch selbst werde so rüberkommt so
das rüberkommt und das meine ich jetzt
nicht ich bin ich nicht abgebrüht und
abgezockt oder meine leidenschaft
besteht diese authentizität wie sie das
nennen natürlich zu stilisieren und die
sog zu drehen bis es nicht mehr weiter
kommission der ist ja unfassbar
authentische orte würde weil ich das
andere nicht kann ist sozusagen eine
übersteuerte echt richtig dass
wahrscheinlich kann das andere nicht
also ich würde nicht auf die idee komme
ich mal musste er gehörte ohne lust dazu
nicht nur die läger dazu gehört die lust
dazu sich zu verkleiden
es wäre lustig 912 anders zu erfinden
das so hat jeder seinen weg was er tue
gemacht das liegt mir aber nicht das ist
nicht meine welt aber gleichzeitig
verweist ich mich dann in der art und
weise für intensiviere das was ich kann
ja wenn ihr noch kurz bei diesen
popbusiness bleiben ist ein buch in die
hände gekommen der song maschinen von
seebruck ein journalist bei dem new
yorker der beschreibt minutiös wie heute
die popindustrie funktioniert und er
sagt im grunde genommen eigentlich ist
die ganze popindustrie heute ein eine
maschinerie popstars werden gemacht da
werden von ganzen teams songs
geschrieben die werden dann versehen
eingespielt mit so nennt man das mit so
wiederkehren melodien an den man sich
festklammern kann
zum teil ist die person die sich
eigentlich primär schön und das ist gar
nicht viel dahinter würden sie sagen das
hat sich wirklich massiv verändert
hätten sie aus herbert grönemeyer heute
in dieser industrie noch eine chance
oder ist das wirklich ein komplett
anderes gewässer
heutzutage also das würde ich nicht ganz
den beschreibt die richtig die die
messwerte und es wird wahnsinnig die
masse produziert dass davon nicht
unterstellt also wenn ich weiß nicht was
im verhältnis und haben wir mal früher
kam im jahr 1500 platten raus kommen
heute 28.000 im jahre aus 30 das heißt
es wird unfassbar masse produziert und
da es ist nach wie vor natürlich
irrsinnig komplett kompliziert und
komplex das zu finden was früher offener
lag also früher konnte man nicht
entscheiden zwischen die stones doors
und beatles zeiten da war relativ offen
da gab es noch bei under grateful dead
oder heute gibt es gibt es die auch noch
ich brauche dazu gibt es nach wie vor
aber dazwischen sind abstufung und jungs
und dann gibt's massen das klebt also
wird verklebt aufträgt unheimlich viel
masse und da ist es eher sie nicht
kompliziert eben etwas zu finden was was
eben eine kraft hat was eine
künstlerische qualität hat da muss man
halt mehr suchen man muss man suchen und
gleichzeitig stimmte beschreibt das
richtig die politik industrie produziert
ja wie am fließband musik aber das ganze
netz das kommen wir wieder zum internet
wieder das ist produzierte auch alles
wird ja im grunde um ins netz gefeiert
also alles was film angeht
und jetzt ist die frage kann die kultur
dagegen stand halten das heißt cancan
qualität sich danach wie vor bleibt die
vorhanden oder lässt die sich die kanten
abschleifen und das ist ja der kampf den
man hat aber trotzdem glaube ich nach
wie vor welche heute in der lage oder es
gibt ja auch heute ich habe selber und
auch ein plattenlabel und aber die auch
mit jungen künstlern gibt nach wie vor
heute künstler die sich aufgrund ihrer
qualität durchsetzen und nicht das
gibt's schon mal und es geht doch in
meinen auch die genau die gleiche gute
musik sie haben zeit im jahr 2000 dieses
grönland label gegründet das haben sie
gerade erwähnt eine gruppe ist boy ein
hamburger zürcherischen schauen wir
gemeinsam rheinhotel aus dem zweiten
bogen wie wir hier
sie verlegen sozusagen mit ihrem label
dich
gruppe b haben sie fast schon so etwas
wie väterliche gefühle welche generation
unterschied an die ja ich mag das leben
ich habe zwei dieses label leighton
hatte die sind zum glück nicht im einmal
23 jahre junge aber ich bin schon
ich versuche ihm sowie hat väterlicher
freund so ab und zu schreien und zu
überlegen und zu helfen oder auch was in
frage zu stellen oder an mir kann man
sich reiben wenn man möchte
trotzdem wir ihnen natürlich eine
generation die deutlich weiter weg ist
aber nehmen sie die musik ja selbst
schon ja wo es teure ganz tun merkt also
beide auch sehr sehr tolle musiker und
auch ein toller mensch
sie haben am anfang des gesprächs auch
gesagt sie werden in diesen tagen 60
jahre auf das ist ja auch wahrscheinlich
ein moment für nachdenklichkeit ich
frage mich manchmal wenn man älter wird
jetzt noch überhaupt nicht aus dass man
dann wirklich wirklich elsa jetzt gibt's
ja wahrscheinlich auf den moment wo man
merkt der mensch ist ja auch das wesen
das gerne spuren hinterlassen möchte
eigentlich wünscht man sich dass da was
bleibt und von ihnen wird unglaublich
viel bleiben aber diese platten zum
beispiel junge gruppen die in ihrem
label erscheinen
finden sie dass er tröstlich oder
manchmal auch ein bisschen bedrohlich
was man da alles drin zurücklässt habe
ich noch nicht drüber nachgedacht
ich habe da nie ich habe also ich denke
auch nie drüber nach was ich bisher
alles schon gemacht habe oder sodass wir
feld an und auch wenn ihr mann dann
zeigen wie wenn man 60 wäre ein film
dreht oder in dieser oder mund oder
biografie liest man selber denkt so
nicht als ich der ich denke so nicht ich
hab da noch nicht so drüber nachgedacht
weil ich denke immer nur in das mache
ich jetzt eigentlich oder was möchte ich
jetzt oder wann merke ich dass ich
wieder dass ich wieder was möchte ich
denk an dich nicht in kategorien dass
ich was hinterlasse und ich hoffe dass
ich dass ich meine kinder hinterlasse
irgendwie zufrieden und dass dieses
leben zugewandt sind aber was man so an
werk schafft oder was man es mir nicht
ist mir auch ein bisschen fremd also
jetzt nicht was sich also ich wunder
mich dann selber erich dann alte sachen
hören oder sehen
ist vielleicht weil ist einfach
hinreichend gut ist ich zum beispiel
sage immer mein mann bitte wenn ich dann
mal sterbe dann werden sofort alle meine
tagebücher verbrannt ich habe dafür
kannst du dir die sendung nur angucken
wie tagebuch ja das gehört man aber
sehen sie jetzt auch interessant man
bewahrt dinge auf oder ich tue das
zumindest obwohl ich weiß sobald ich tot
bin möchte ich sofort vernichtet wissen
ja das hat man es dann auf das war
vielleicht selber also ich schreibe kein
tagebuch aber dass man vielleicht
einfach später mal nachgeguckt was war
da denn das ist bei mir wie ein wunder
sind meine platten auch eine art von
tagebuch also was ich erschreckend finde
oft also lieder haben mit mit für mich
als person noch immer ganz andere
bedeutung also nicht was im text steht
sondern die stehen natürlich eine ganz
spezielle zeit also nicht in der also
liegt kann sich doch mit angst
beschäftigen kann also wahr heißt nicht
dass ich jetzt angst hatte aber ich weiß
ganz genau wann ich das geschrieben habt
das spiel bringt bringt mich sofort in
diese zeit zurück und jede platte hat
also ich kann da nicht von kommt auch
nicht von weg insofern höre ich auch
ungern alte platten weil die sofort
wieder dahin gebäude zurückgeworfen
werde wo ich und das gefühl bekommt
sofort wieder einfach nicht dass und das
bei tagebuch ähnlich glaube ich da ein
buch ist ja was du weisst du warst du
damit in der zeit und so hast du gedacht
und das hatte ich betreue berührt oder
das natürlich besorgt oder aber dass man
jetzt so darüber nachdenkt was man
hinterlässt bleibt bin ich der sich das
dann auch wieder zu sehr als pop
das wird glaube ich wirklich denke wird
ehrliche antwort sein ich glaube nicht
dass das ich schreibe das ja auch für
den moment ich schreibe meine lieder für
den moment weil ich gerne auf die bühne
gehen möchte mit dem neuen programm und
den leuten in dem moment was schönes vor
sinken so das ist und ich auch selber
recht zu hause vorm ich ihn spiele was
schönes mir selber vor sich
also ohne deckt das den ganzen tag auch
jetzt wieder schreibt wieder neue lieder
und die sich dann stellt sich das
klavier und freue mich jetzt kann ich
das lied so und wenn ich dass der
öffentlich sind dann investors oder hat
auch seinen zweck erfüllt fast schon
aber ich schreibe die dinge nicht weil
ich denke das hat dann nachträglich ich
bin selber er manchmal verblüfft was
dann lieder für eine bedeutung haben als
es gibt ein lied auf 12 das heißt
flüstern derzeit das beschäftigt sich
genau damit was wir jetzt haben nämlich
dass die politik zu wenig mit denen mit
der bevölkerung rede und plötzlich nach
rechts zu rücken
da wundert man sich das habe ich vor 10
also neun jahren geschrieben ich feuchte
zug lupe und das 101 er dann aber
letztendlich ist das alles nur material
und dann auf die bühne zu gehen und den
leuten ein abend zu machen bieten wie
neues theaterstück so jetzt muss ich
etwas fragen wovon ich immer denke das
kann doch einfach gar nicht ihr ernst
sein die sagen in ganz vielen interviews
das sind die text eigentlich gar nicht
so wichtig sein zuerst kommt die musik
die musik ist ihnen wichtiger
ich persönlich mag ihre texte sehr wie
sehr viele glaube ich das sieht man auch
in den kommentaren auf amazon die neue
broadway
da gibt es ganz viele leute die unten
bei amazon den kommentaren hin schreiben
die texte einfach fantastisch und sie
selber haben ein buch mitgebracht mascha
kaleko gedichte die sie gerne lesen sie
hatten poetikvorlesungen aber sie sind
ja schon einer der mit den worten hat
und der sich in texte verliebt und in
texte vertrauen
ja das ist auch das kommt aber das wird
falsch geschrieben ich habe ich versuche
den vorgang des schreibens über ich
schreibe inzwischen sehr gerne texte und
ich nehme dir auch ernst aber ich
schreibe immer erst den sieg und die
musik ist für mich das ist mein träger
das ist mein das ist ein
geschmacksträger der trägt das ganze und
wenn diesen sieg nicht stark genug ist
oder nicht
anrührend genug ist dann fehlt dann kann
auch der beste text nichts retten und
und dann kommt der text dazu das ist
hier heute als erster schon mal ganz
nicht nachvollziehbar und für mich hat
das duo dessen kommt diese das ist ein
irrtum ich schreibe natürlich meine
texte sehr sorgfältig weil ich auch
meine musik nicht kaputt machen möchte
und inzwischen mag sprache ich war jetzt
nicht derjenige der sich ein leben lang
mit sprache beschäftigt hat aber als ich
dann getan aber habe ich ja auch
vernünftig gefahren so wie sie es
beschreiben aber dass er hat sich falsch
übertragen ich habe nur gesagt ich sei
allerdings vor das erste richtige ich
glaube meine texte sind nicht das
einzige was was die menschen anrühren
ich glaube die die die sie achten auf
die texte weil weil ich weiß natürlich
auch was erzählen aber unter ohne die
unterfütterung der musik hätten die
lange nicht diese wirkung
klar es ist glaube ich der und ich
glaube einfach mal ich halte meine musik
etwas schöner als meine texte an weil
ich mich da auch mehr zu hause fühle und
text ist für mich ein sehr
konzentriertes arbeiten und das mag ich
inzwischen aber es ist ein kampf aber
dass nach den wird in jeder sagen der
der bücher schreibt aber auch literatur
lyrik
es ist eben auch ein kampf und musik
schreibe ich mit mir lust und texte mit
mehr kannte aber gerade weil ich in
ihren texten so viel poesie finde habe
ich im vorfeld gefragt was sie denn
eigentlich so lesen und dann haben sie
mascha kaleko gedichte mitgebracht was
neben der mascha kaleko mannschaft
kaléko beschreibt das leben also in der
ganzen im ganzen umfang ist eine
berlinerin die emigrieren musste nach
nach new york und daneben in der
emigration sehr viel heimweh hatte für
deutschland schrieb natürlich auch für
die gerade über die den faschismus und
umgekehrt aber gleichzeitig noch etwas
berlinerisch sehr werden unfassbar
melancholischen frohsinn sie mich den
melancholischen frühjahr das ist richtig
das zeichnet sie aus er hat auf der
einen seite diese diese dieser
herzzerreißende melancholie die sich
aber immer wieder
auflöst und auch wegschubst und und
kämpft mit indem sie diesen berliner
diese berliner freche schnauze hat
werden das ist lohnt sich wirklich zu
lesen
hier sind sind wunderschöne gedichte und
und und auch ihre biografie ist lohnt
aber und die beschreibt das an sich ganz
gut also dieses spannungsfeld glaube ich
auch die bei meinen texten sind die auf
der einen seite sich dem schicksal
stellen und gleichzeitig aber auch dem
schicksal auch umgekehrt die schönheit
abzugewinnen und auch wirklich die
momente und dieses dieses geschenk das
wir auf diese dieser erde sind in diesem
film mitspielen dürfen das ist schon
auch ein unfassbares geschenke gehen wir
noch mal zurück zum menschen uns zur
authentizität sie haben ja gesagt sie
seien vor allem künstlich authentisch
mit da aber was nicht daran auch sehr
interessiert ist dass dieser ganze zwang
dazu echt zu sein der mit unsere zeit ja
auch aus zwar schöningen wir unser
facebook profil war waren es ja auch
davon auf einem auf dem stück uniform
auf ihrer neuen platte aber trotzdem
gibt es zu diesen zwang dazu mach was
aus dir werde dich selbst fahren das
wäre die selbst verwirklichen dich und
das macht uns auch ein stückweit müde
oder kann uns auch überfordern
ich frage mich an dieser stelle vor
allem immer was ist das eigentlich genau
wie ein bild glauben sie gibt in uns
drin so was wie den echten herbert
grönemeyer die echte barbara bleisch die
man irgendwie werden kann
das glaube ich nicht ich glaube nicht
dass es gibt nicht nehmen sie sind
vielschichtig wir sind selber auch jeder
einzelne weniger und universum und das
wahnsinnig vielschichtig er kennt sich
eben auch selber nicht was ich ja vorher
auch schon gesagt habe sondern man kann
ja auch nicht ich selbst werden wenn man
nur 50 prozent von sich kennt das ist so
das ist ein neuer nazismus ist die
aufforderung
jeder ist ja inzwischen auch sein
eigener promoter was wir früher
planmäßig an mit mit fachleuten auch
wenn wir eine platte veröffentlicht
geplant haben das macht jeder selber
also eigene promotion ständig die ich ag
und das er läuft sich ist einfach im
grunde ist es ja ermüdend und auch
wirklich der fast tragisch zum teil weil
man ja immer wieder futter braucht man
braucht immer wieder neues futter
inzwischen ist ja auch wenn ich also
früher musste ich noch autogramme
schreiben und musik autogramme schreiben
und zählen ließ machen damit auch jeder
natürlich sagen kann
nein das ist dieses mal muss ein latent
sein ich befeuern weil sonst wird man
plötzlich wenn man hat damit angefangen
und jetzt muss man dranbleiben sonst
fällt man aus dieser aus dieser bewegung
aus dieser bewegung aus ich glaube dass
sich das irgendwann sowieso von alleine
wieder gibt weil das ist auf dauer nicht
durchzuhalten das ist einfach dass das
macht ein möbel und ist auch langweilig
wenn man von morgens bis abends sich
selber in szene setzen muss also und ich
muss das ja schon von berufswegen das
ist schon anstrengend aber ich das
private mir überlegen das will ich auch
machen oder generell machen finde ich
das völlig langweilig also findet kultur
passen ist ich nenne überhaupt nicht ich
bin nicht pessimistisch ich glaube dass
ich die dinge immer dann irgendwann
wieder auch relativieren die
relativieren sich
früher hat man auch geschrieben kein
mensch die videos gern kein mensch geht
mehr ins kino
ich glaube dass läuft sich leer die
faszination wird sich leerlaufen es wird
irgendwann an was verlieren oder die
menschen werden bemerken aha es steckt
auch viel mehr schöner darin dass ich
wirklich auch nicht per internet 739
freunde oder 370 sondern ich gehe lieber
mit zwei einen kaffee trinken oder ruft
ihr an unser wir treffen uns umsätzen
aus dem verkauf der bank und gucken blöd
den leuten die die politik glauben zu
ich glaube aus dieser daraus wird wieder
was entstehen dass man sehnsucht hat
einfach nacheinander nähern haben dass
man im moment die menschen treffen
möchte und und sich nicht latent mit
seiner eigenen promotion beschäftigen
muss das wird sicherlich wäre natürlich
bin locker gut tut wissen will ich
glaube dass das netz eben auf der
anderen seite eine schönheit hat weil es
gibt wunderbare film gerade von einem
preis bauern dem in bangladesch der das
wasser war verschmutzt dann ging die
wasserverschmutzung immer mehr durch und
der aber dann frei kamera stand und vor
zehn jahren hätte man gedacht der könnte
jetzt was von seinem dorf erzählen euro
er wusste alles fragen die kamera
bewussten komplett was auf der welt
passiert wo seine syrischen russische
familien hin gehen was wir denn wie er
jetzt mal denkt schon darüber nach wo er
wohl hingehen könnte also was war das
ernte ist wird zerstört und die
schönheit ist ja das ist natürlich eine
schönheit weil das natürlich auch leute
auch wissen bringt darin steckt
natürlich eine schöne so ein großes
vertrauen in die menschheit in die welt
dass sie letztendlich mitbringen
dieser optimismus den sie auch
auszeichnet wenn wir noch einmal über
dieses diesen diese idee sprechen was
sie vielleicht zum kern haben das finden
sie ist er nicht der fall
aber was wir haben können oder was wir
tun können ist ein plan schmieden und
das raten sie auch an ihm mit pilot
singen sie eigentlich davon dass man dem
plan den man schmiedet treu bleiben
sollen zwar auch trotzig treu bleiben
soll
ich komme man zu seinem plan wenn man
selber nicht diesen kern hat den mann in
ihren becken kann die macht man einen
plan im leben wenn jemand haltung
bezieht den plan kann man schmieden auch
ohne dass man ja ständig noch sagen
einen kern sucht aber indem man der
haltung bezieht
sich verhält man sich zum menschen fehlt
in dem man sich respektvoll und
mitfühlend mit menschen verhält und sich
auch gegen dinge verhält die einem nicht
passen das ist ja das große thema ich
glaube wir haben alle nicht gelernt also
wir merken jetzt deutschland nehmen im
moment dann haben wir so eine zum
rechten rechter geist der sich breit
macht oder jetzt sagen wir das kennen
wir ja wir am kfd und ganz stehen sitzen
wir jetzt im grunde um so da wie wir ihn
immer versucht haben uns vorzustellen
wie war das damals eigentlich bei den
nazis weil wir das gerne miterlebt jetzt
müssen wir plötzlich erleben wir dass
wichtig so ein geist breit macht und
dann aber im moment gucken wir noch zu
wir wissen ja gar nicht wie wir damit
umgehen
aber wir wissen auch nicht was jetzt das
mittel um mit dem umzugehen sagen dass
wir ihn alle bekloppt oder diesen befund
dass nämlich das thema das thema ist
plötzlich wie geht man mit so einer
strömung um also was passiert da nicht
gerade
und das glaube ich ist nur machbar wenn
man wenn man eben in dieser zeit die
völlig anders ist als damals aber eben
lernt haltung zu beziehen und er auch
nicht zu verhalten und andere sagt so
sehe ich die dinge und ich möchte nicht
dass ich da hin entwickelt und nicht es
ist im moment alles schwammig es ist
alles total schwammig und keiner sagt
auch was es ist alles im fluss ich
glaube man kann zum sich finden indem
man einfach haltung zu viele leute haben
zu allen erhalten wenn man die
kommentare auf und löst sie ihre anguckt
löst sich alles so auf weil keine
stellung beziehen wurde in meinem bett
rum prügelt oder oder oder verbal also
völlig haltlos sich aus aus schmeißt
aber ich glaube man kann zu sich finden
indem man einfach hat und bezieht in dem
man gegenüber seinen freunden seine
waren seine ideen und auch gegen diesen
rechten geil oder eben auch menschen
verteidigt also menschen die kommen dass
dazu brauche ich eine alterung und und
so ängste geschürt und dann bezieht
keiner sagt ehrlich ängsten völlig
absurd ich war doch gar nicht worüber
die eigentlich wo vor die eigentlich
angst haben ich meine es ist bisher noch
nichts passiert was uns in irgendeiner
form in unserem westlichen saturiert hat
irgendwo nur annähernd eingeschränkt hat
nichts noch gar nichts es ist absurd da
ist noch wir reden hier während wir sind
in deutschland 80 millionen menschen
haben es im moment an schreiber eine
million das ist auf 80 personen kommt
einer einer das ist ein witz also ist
ein witz das ist gar nichts das ist
bisher und es hat uns auch noch nicht
wir sind jetzt auch noch nicht verarmt
noch lange nicht und irgendwann aber
trotzdem entsteht eine eine imaginäre
angst wurde somit kann man jetzt einmal
klar stellung beziehen
was soll der quatsch ja es gibt wovor
haben wir eine chance haben beziehen
hast da sein stück weit auch wieder zur
menschlichkeit zu regeln über die jahren
ja wohl nur das ist das ist das ist und
das glauben wir aber nie trainiert das
hat uns auch keiner beigebracht das hat
uns auch die menschlichkeit keiner weise
brach und das muss man lernen und das
muss man muss unsere das sind dinge und
sagt da kann man sich dann auch finden
das ist auf jeden persönlich ist
training man eben in dieser
menschlichkeit denn so menschlichkeit so
findet man sie werden das spürt man sich
plötzlich auch wenn man eben menschen
verteidigt und darauf so geht das nicht
was worüber reden wir hier ich meine
wenn jemand jetzt hier auf der straße
liegen würde verbluten gar nicht sein
die nehme ich jetzt die lage immer
weiter von blut ich muss gerade mal ich
habe noch kurz ich hab tennistraining
nee da geht man hin und hilft dem und
den menschen geht es verdammt schlecht
und ich komme aus einer notlage das
vergessen die aber alle inzwischen weil
jetzt machen sie noch angst
dennoch kann ich will die menschen geht
etwa an die alle noch furchtbare angst
und ist alles ganz friedlich so gar
nichts passiert es ist noch nichts
passiert außer eben das ist fanatiker
gibt das hat aber mit den menschen
nichts zu tun
aber die menschen selber und das glaube
ich man kann haltung ich glaube es ist
eine frage
wenn man erlebt sich selber besser wenn
man haltung bezieht sowie das vielleicht
vielleicht damit was jetzt gerade gesagt
haben schließen wir das ist ein
richtiges plädoyer für die
menschlichkeit das jetzt zum schluss uns
gegeben haben
ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich möchte
aber abschließend mit einem zitat von
ihnen das noch einmal einfach sooo
wunderbar denn vielleicht kommt man
sagen zärtlichen herbert grönemeyer mit
dem trotzigen herbert grönemeyer und
auch den humor von herbert grönemeyer
verbindet in der not mache ich es
verkehrt ich danke ihnen sehr
[Musik]